[Music]
the new Colossus by Emma Lazarus not
like the brazen giant of Greek fame with
conquering limbs astride from land to
land here at our sea-washed sunset gates
shall stand a mighty woman with a torch
whose flame is the imprisoned lightning
and her name mother of exiles from her
beacon hand glows worldwide welcomed her
mild eyes command the air bridged Harbor
that Twin Cities frame keep ancient
lands your storied pomp cries she with
silent lips give me your tired your poor
your huddled masses yearning to breathe
free the wretched refuse of your teeming
Shore send these the homeless
tempest-tossed to me I lift my lamp
beside the Golden Door
[Music]
for an analysis of the poem watch this
video or check out the next poem in this
series
[Music]